[Music]
wakanda is ingenuity wakanda is Hope
wakanda is Excellence wakanda is family
I think that the Black Panther films
have been so successful in the black
community because
this is something that we haven't seen
before typically in movies that show our
community we are overcoming we've been
victimized in this film we're not we are
the Kings and the Queens we are
empowered wakanda really is that Beacon
of Hope it is that idea of this African
nation that has never been colonized we
haven't seen black people be this
beautiful we haven't seen black people
represent leadership in this way black
people represent intelligence and quite
frankly they're the smartest people on
the planet Earth and the people who are
leading us to progression into a better
place just the ability for them to unite
themselves and conquer any obstacle that
celebrates women and girls and their
leadership I think a lot of people
resonated with that not just black folks
but I think everyone because honestly
this is a universal story
[Music]
I am an artifice I am an entertainment
journalist I am a doctor I am an artist
and I am wakanda I am wakanda I am
wakanda
I'm wakanda